so the other week there was an
interesting announcement from Google in
that they had had to update YouTube
because sighs a popular music video
Gangnam style had managed to amass as so
many views that it overflowed the 32-bit
integer that they were using to store
view counts as I thought it'd be
interesting to just take a look and
remind yourself of how computers store
numbers and to see exactly why it
actually broke youtube so signage to
amass two billion one hundred and forty
seven million four hundred and eighty
three thousand six hundred and forty
seven views on YouTube for his video so
the computer stores is information in
binary and if we've got just one bit of
information one binary digit then we can
store two values zero or one on the
other hand if we have two bits of
information and so we represent this as
two boxes then we can store for
different values because we can put a
zero in both boxes we can put a zero in
the first box and the one in the second
we can put a 1 in the first box and a
zero in the second box and we can put a
1 in both boxes so we've got four
possible values that we can store now
just like when we count in normally
using decimal system we got powers of 10
each of these boxes represents we've got
the first one represents ones or two to
the power 0 and the second one
represents the twos or two to the power
of one and so if we add them together
we've got no twos and no ones and we get
zero no twos and one so we get one one
two and no ones we get 2 1 2 and 1 1 and
we get 3 so you can store four possible
values from naught through to 3 if we do
the same with 3 bits 0 4s + 0 - 0 1
which is 0 0 4 + 0 - 4 0 was 1 1 is 1
and so on 2 3 4 5 6 & 7
apologies for the handwriting
and it's exactly the same thing we can
do we can extend this and every time we
add an extra bit we double the amount of
information we can store so I can store
eight numbers with three bits two to the
power of three if we had four 2 to the
power 3 gives us 8 2 to the power of 4
would give us 16 numbers it doubles
again we can store 0 through 15 and 2 to
the 8 gives us 256 different values 0
through 255 and it extends up now
YouTube because their computers were
probably when they started writing and
implementing this running 32-bit
operating systems uses a standard 32-bit
integer to store the view count makes
sense is the default on many systems and
you think 2 billion or so views was
unlikely to be amassed when if you think
about that's a third of the planet
perhaps watching one video you'd think
some of them would have actually
something better to do with their lives
so a 32-bit system 2 to the power of 32
gives us 4 billion 294 million nine
hundred and sixty-seven thousand two
hundred and ninety six possible numbers
that we can store that's 0 through to 4
billion 294 million nine hundred and
sixty-seven thousand two hundred and
ninety-five so they're all the values
that we can store what YouTube break
when it got past two billion but that's
only half the amount you can fit in a
32-bit integer well computers can also
store negative numbers and the way they
do that is by using some of the bit
patterns the zeros and ones that make of
that 32-bit integer to mean negative
numbers and others to mean positive
numbers so we get 2 billion positive
numbers and two billion negative numbers
either side of 0 we can see this if we
consider a slightly simplest situation
using only 8 bits or a single byte now
the way computers store negative numbers
they use what's called the two's
complement system and we'll do another
video at some time that goes into
exactly how that works and the other
systems that we used in the past but the
basic thing to remember is at the top
bit bit sevens if your number bit 0 down
here 0 1 2 3
four five six seven so it's seven here
effectively stores the sign if it's zero
it's a positive number if it's one then
it's a negative number we have hundred
twenty seven in decimal and we add one
we obviously get 128 128 in binary would
be 1 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 and remember what I
said the top bit bit 7 says with it's
positive or negative when we've gone
from being positive 127 to negative 128
this has been what was called an
overflow error on the computer system
because we've overflowed the range we
can store positive integers and gone
back round into negative integers and
this is exactly the same that would have
happened on YouTube if they'd added 1 to
size hit count because it had gone from
being positive to billion etc which is a
high something they could store in a
signed 32-bit integer to a negative
minus 2 billion etc which is the lowest
negative number they could store so you
might be asking well why can't they just
switch to using unsigned integers why do
they decide to go up to using the 64 bit
number which obviously gave them a lot
more space several quintillion values to
store when they just use an unsigned but
that would double the number they could
store one of the things you find which
is why it's considered bad practice when
writing software is it's certain simple
calculations go wrong so for example say
I want you to subtract two numbers say I
want to subtract the numbers 5 & 3 we
wanted to find out what the difference
is
well we subtract one from the other and
we get the number 2 so on the other hand
in order to find the difference between
123 and 200 we do the same we subtract
one from the other now in a sign system
that's fine you get a minus 77 and you
can run that through a function to get
the absolute value in C probably be
called abs or abs and so we can find the
difference which is ever way around
quite easily but if we're using unsigned
integers we can't store the value minus
numbers so we'd end up with getting
random very big numbers appearing
instead of a simple difference that we'd
expect so the point of view of YouTube
is
might be that they want to work out how
many views they've had between two
points and there they had exfuze on
Tuesday they've now got Y views on
Wednesday subtract Y from X or X from Y
and something if you do one way it works
if you do it the other way it doesn't
and so it's considered bad practice when
you're writing software that must be
reliable and it's in Google style guide
for programming which we can link to
that you shouldn't use unsigned numbers
so what they've done is they've taken it
from being signed 32-bit numbers to sign
64-bit numbers to get that range they
need
seventeen thousand four hundred and
thirty two years so that's how many
years it would have taken one person to
a watch Gangnam style to break YouTube